our president who I now am thinking of
my new nickname for Trump is president
big Li smalls remember biggie smalls the
great rapper maybe that was part I
Gordon Oh Biggie's fair and of course
president big li smalls Donald Trump
sent a tweet on the morning of April
first then I was sure was some kind of
April Fool's joke but it turns out that
it was no joke whatsoever Donald Trump
tweeted at roughly 8:00 in the morning
that this is five in the morning but
that specific time Pat operates on
Pacific time on the show so that's why
all the tweets are Pacific time but you
know I keep telling Pat hey we are on
the East Coast here you know I'm kidding
around but in all seriousness Donald
Trump tweeting when will sleepy eyes
Chuck Todd and NBC News start talking
about the Obama surveillance scandal and
stop with the fake Trump Russia story
that's right Donald Trump is telling
Chuck Todd and NBC News what is news and
what isn't news
imagine during Watergate I'm sure
Richard Nixon would have loved to decide
what was news and what wasn't news
especially with regard to the
investigation of Woodward and Bernstein
and I didn't even mention this yet but
it bears mentioning the President of the
United States is making fun of people's
appearance on Twitter how is that
helping you at home make more money or
get your kids a better education or
dealing with the climate crisis Trump is
tweeting insults about a journalists
physical appearance on social media and
Trump's implication that this is just a
media story this is similar to last week
when Sean Spicer said Oh Trump Russia
yeah it's done everybody's being cleared
and then we realize hey Sean there's at
minimum three investigations into Trump
Russia FBI Senate Intel committee and
House Intel committee uh this has all
the hallmarks of authoritarianism and
and also just somebody who is desperate
to distract from the realities of what's
going on you know it's interesting a few
months back a congressman by the name of
Lamar Smith said that you might as well
just get your news directly from the
president yeah it's a great idea that
it's a great thing that we have a free
press in this country because you have
to keep people in power like the
president accountable recall that Donald
Trump seemed to think that Obama
supposedly wiretapping him was news of
course as soon as media and official
agencies started
looking into it they found no evidence
and the entire thing imploded this is
the authoritarian stuff that I've been
talking about the idea that Donald Trump
can tell media what to talk about and
what not to talk about how does someone
see Trump doing this see him tweeting
that he doesn't like the coverage about
a scandal involving him in a foreign
power and think oh this is a strong
leader this is who I want making
decisions that impact my security
extrapolating from the past
I wonder if Trump has caught wind that
NBC has some major bombshell and he's
doing this to preempt it the way we've
seen done before and what he's doing is
completely counterproductive because if
the media realizes that this is getting
under her skin they're going to keep
digging into it because they're going to
think that there's clearly something
there the last thing you want to do is
give either the intelligence community
or media more reason to look into an
issue you don't want them talking about
if there's really nothing there don't
start telling people not to talk about
it let it run its course and nothing
will come up the only reason you would
actually be doing this is if you're
worried about what the results might
bring